[Musique]
vous allez nous parler d'un problème qui
pourrait paraître dérisoire mais qui en
fait a provoqué la mort d'enfants donc
puisqu'il ya mort de personne c'est un
problème important
il s'agit des sanisettes six mois de sa
vie fut 18 mois à noël vous l'avez
sûrement remarqué sur les trottoirs de
paris et sur les trottoirs de toute la
france ont surgi des bâtisses
encombrante des sortes de blockhaus
qu'on utilise comme toilettes et qui ont
pour noms sanisettes tout cela serait
très drôle et très très pratique si le 8
août dernier une petite fille n'était
pas restée coincée à l'intérieur
et s'ils n'étaient pas décédés par la
suite on ne sait pas encore les
circonstances de l'accident
une commission d'enquêté a été nommée
elle n'a pas encore rendu ses
conclusions
mais cela nous a suffi pour nous pencher
sur le problème de la sécurité des 117
malheureusement jean claude decaux ne
nous a pas accordé d'interview et nous
nous sommes contentés de faire tout
bonnement l'expérience des sanisettes il
faut remarquer que les sanisettes sont
eux une idée du à l'initiative de
monsieur de coûts
pour le néophyte entré dans une salle
disette est une drôle de manoeuvre vous
lisez d'abord attentivement les modes
d'emploi
mais attention à leur curieusement le
système de marges que de 6 heures à une
heure du matin le lendemain puis vous
mettez une pièce de 1 franc chose
indispensable pour que la porte s'ouvre
une fois dans cet univers clos et
désodoriser détendez vous la musique
vous y aidera pour sortir il faut aussi
vous dépêcher pas trop quand même
les sanisettes donne sur la voie
publique alentour mais d'un coup et plus
grand bien
dans l'absolu vous ne risquez rien dès
votre entrée le sol détecte votre
présence par tapie contact 10 kg
suffisent pour le socre reste en place
pourtant le 8 août dernier une petite
fille de 5 ans s'est trouvé coincé dans
la cuvette gravement intoxiqué la
fillette est morte à l'hôpital
depuis l'accident comme on dit chez de
qu une autre sécurité a été installé
lorsque la cuvette supporter un poids de
6 kg tout le système reste bloquée de
plus l'entrée des sanisettes a été
interdite aux enfants non accompagnés
mais même si la sécurité des enfants est
désormais plus ou moins bien assurée
plusieurs interrogations demeurent
notamment sur le bien fondé d'un tel
système
est ce qu'on peut dire que votre enfant
est dehors pour faire pipi plutôt que
dans les sanisettes bas parce que ça me
paraît plus simple
c'est plus pratique pour lui un sauna g
puis
reste un souvenir d'articles
un enfant à utiliser
cet appareil est oui
ça n'a pas bien fonctionné il est tombé
dedans et
je crois qu'il a été assez
et c'est peut-être mon métier décédé je
sais pas
la ville de revin dépenses la ville de
paris veut mettre 400 sanisettes dans
paris qu'est ce que vous en pensez
pour des adultes ça me paraît tout à
fait adapté
pour l'exemple moment
je continuerai à lui faire faire comme
moi même j'ai fait à varilhes
bien sûr les sanisettes sont moins
polluantes plus hygiénique
mais qu'est-il prévu en fait comme
sorties de secours si quelqu'un par
exemple est pris d'un malaise à
l'intérieur aussi liée à une panne
d'électricité et bien au bout de 20
minutes
une alarme se met en route les pompiers
théoriquement arrive ensuite il enlève
le dessus une sorte de couverte par
lequel vous êtes censé sortir d'un
emploi incommode d'une hyper technicité
les sanisettes sont inesthétiques et
encombrantes pour un sanitaire de un
mètre cinquante de long il faut trois
mètres cinquante de local technique ce
qui fait plus de 4 mètres carrés occupés
par des toilettes dans l'année jean
claude decaux prévoit d'installer 400
sanisettes dans paris 1,7 kilomètre
carré de trottoir seront ainsi enlever
aux pieds d'eau les trottoirs
deviendront malheureusement le simple
crottoirs justement mais c'est de quoi
un problème est que cette idée
apparemment génial de sanisettes
pourquoi ne dit pas voulu vous répondre
il ne m'a pas dit précisément qu'il ne
voulait pas me répondre mais jamais ça
sent attaché de presse m'a promis scoop
magnifique d'ici trois semaines ou un
mois et baisse à l'est les pas marqué ma
carrière que je préférais tout de suite
faire leur portage puisque beaucoup de
gens se posent des questions sur la
sécurité dans les sanisettes mais alors
ce monsieur decaux a l'intention d'en
installer beaucoup de sanisettes en
france tout 10 400 à paris nos chiffres
n'est pas donnée pour la france
puisqu'il ya de résidence et que
monsieur de coûts continuent à installer
les sanisettes alors que la mairie de
paris dit qu'elle continue à étudier le
dossier
ça peut-être préférable d'abord
d'étudier le dossier d installer ensuite
le celle inverse qui se produit en a qui
sont construites mais ne sont pas encore
couvertes notamment dans le 15e
arrondissement bien est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à ajouter sur ce point
précis des sanisettes que vous avez
présenté qui me parle
problème très important pour les le
contact humain moi je préfère encore les
dames pipi et porcelaines des vieux
bistrot
[Musique]